[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Hello, and
welcome to Public Speaking Pro
Tips with Speechless,
presented by Google Developers.
We help people turn the
mundane into the memorable.
ARJITA SETHI: Challenges
into insights.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
And presentations
into performances.
ARJITA SETHI: Today
we'll deal with something
called the illusion
of the first time.
It's what great
speakers do to help
make the presentation feel
fresh and exciting every time
you watch it.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Even if it's
the 50th time you're seeing it.
ARJITA SETHI: So let's jump
in with tip number one.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
The speed through.
You're going to run through
your talk as quickly as you can.
ARJITA SETHI: That's right.
Tempo, tempo, tempo.
This can help you hear your
presentation anew and also find
any pattern that you
may have fallen into,
whether positive or negative.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Sometimes we get
caught in a rut around
how to say each line,
and that can often lead to a
flat or mechanical performance.
We start predicting the rhythm
and anticipating our next line
before we've delivered
the prior one.
ARJITA SETHI: The
speed through forces
you to try your talk in
a new tempo, which can
lead to unexpected discoveries.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Maybe a new
way to phrase a sentence,
or a desire to
take a deep breath.
ARJITA SETHI: And it will
help you to stay in the moment
when you switch back
to the standard tempo.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
The speed through
forces you to try your talk
in a new tempo, which can
lead to unexpected discoveries.
Maybe a new way
to phrase an idea
or a desire to take deep breath.
And it will help you
stay in the moment
when you switch back
to the standard tempo.
ARJITA SETHI: Wow.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: No big deal.
ARJITA SETHI: Let's move
on to tip number two.
Give your talk character.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: So
let's do an exercise
we call three through the door.
You're going to
take the first three
lines of your presentation.
We'll take the first three
lines from the beginning
of this video.
And then you're going to walk
through an imaginary revolving
door three times in character
and perform those opening
lines as that character.
Arjita will demonstrate.
How about for this first
one, do it as a five year.
ARJITA SETHI: OK.
(IN TODDLER VOICE) Hello and
welcome to Public Speaking Pro
Tips with Speechless,
presented by Google Developers.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Now
try it as a zombie.
ARJITA SETHI: OK.
(IN ZOMBIE VOICE) Hello, and
welcome to Public Speaking Pro
Tips with Speechless,
presented by Google Developers.
[ROARING NOISES]
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And
this time as a princess.
ARJITA SETHI: OK.
(IN A GENTLE VOICE) Hello.
And welcome to Public Speaking
Pro Tips with Speechless,
presented by Google Developers.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Fantastic.
ARJITA SETHI: Thanks!
CLAIRE SLATTERY: The key is
to quickly go through the door
and make a bold choice.
Now we're not saying that
you should do your whole talk
as a zombie, but giving yourself
a character to do your talk in
can eliminate moments that you
may have skipped past before.
ARJITA SETHI: Not to
mention it's a lot of fun.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And
if you're having fun,
then your audience is
going to have fun too.
ARJITA SETHI: So
we've given it tempo.
We've given it character.
What's left, Claire?
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Tip number three.
Give it emotion.
ARJITA SETHI: So
let's try something
we call emotional
roller coaster.
Think of the stage or room or
set as three different zones.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: This
will be zone one.
This is zone two.
And all the way over
here is zone three.
ARJITA SETHI: Now
we're going to assign
each zone a different emotion
and have Claire jump back
and forth between all of them.
It's a lot of fun.
Zone one will be excitement,
zone two will be anger,
and zone three will be fear.
And let's start with zone one.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
(EXCITEDLY) Hello,
and welcome to Public Speaking
Pro Tips with Speechless,
presented by Google Developers!
We help people--
ARJITA SETHI: Zone three.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
(SHAKILY) Turn the mundane
into the memorable--
ARJITA SETHI: Zone two.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: (FORCEFULLY)
Challenges into insights and--
ARJITA SETHI: Zone one.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
(EXCITEDLY) Presentations
into performances!
ARJITA SETHI:
Excellent work, Claire.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Thanks!
ARJITA SETHI: This
exercise helps
to remind you that emotions
are a powerful part
of every presentation.
And until you find
the exact emotion,
sometimes it's helpful
to just try random ones
and have fun with it.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: In
all of these exercises,
you're creating healthy
pathways in your brain
around giving presentations.
And that's what we call--
TOGETHER: Improv thinking.
ARJITA SETHI: A quick recap.
We have tip number one,
give your talk tempo.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Tip number
two, give your talk character.
ARJITA SETHI: And
finally, tip number three,
give your talk emotion.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And remember,
check the description
below for links from Google
Developers, Women Techmakers,
and more tips from Speechless on
how to think like an improviser
and develop your voice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]